YouTube has recently done some
fascinating things and I wanted to take
a moment to address those right here
right now in earnest
you've probably heard how YouTube's new
monetization requirements cut off the
ability of millions of channels from
earning additional income by posting
videos online well you probably haven't
heard is that YouTube could potentially
be doing more of this in the future
cutting off more and more channels over
time we believe this is because they're
intentionally moving to a structure
we're only about 10% of their channels
create about 90% of their revenue
obviously this is going to have huge
consequences most surprisingly however
if YouTube continues to go down this
path cutting people off of monetization
I think they're doing it out of
necessity and here's why to understand
how this could possibly be happening
let's first go back and review YouTube's
underlying economic model to understand
what makes the whole site function in
the first place
basically there are three players on
YouTube that create a codependent
ecosystem there are viewers there are
creators and there are advertisers
creators make videos that are seen by
viewers viewers watch advertisements
which are placed in front of videos by
advertisers creators make a portion of
those ad dollars paid by advertisers and
creators then use that money to make
more videos that are seen by more
viewers and so on and so forth it's
cyclical and the whole time YouTube
takes a portion of the revenue that's
generated so if any of these players
begin to outweigh the others the whole
ecosystem begins to get out of whack and
it creates a spiraling effect that could
affect the future of the site let's get
into a little bit more detail here
currently there are 1.3 billion users on
YouTube now in 2012 YouTube opened up
the YouTube partnership program to every
channel meaning that anyone with an
account any user on the site could
potentially monetize their videos by
just signing up for Google Adsense now
I'm not gonna sit here and assumes that
all 1.3 billion users are partaking in
the partnership program but even if just
1% of those channels are that's 13
million partners by comparison back in
YouTube had just 15,000 partners
the YouTube Partnership Program so
that's a growth from 2010 to 2016
on the same timeline the total amount of
ad revenue generated on YouTube has gone
from roughly 1 billion to 10 billion so
why does this matter well by comparison
the growth of the YouTube Partnership
Program has outpaced the growth of ad
revenue generated on YouTube by our
issue of 86 to 1 so well in strictly
financial terms 10 billion dollars is a
tremendous amount of money it's crushed
in comparison to the growth that the
YouTube partnership program has had over
the same period of time what this means
in straightforward terms is that per
capita there's less advertising revenue
to go around than there was in the past
meaning that YouTube can't afford to pay
its creators as much as it could in the
past even though my numbers aren't exact
you can begin to understand the
disproportional growth that's happened
on the partnership side versus the ad
revenue side so you've got a basic
problem too many partners not enough ad
revenue creators who are at the margins
ie creators who are working their butts
off to try to do YouTube's full-time are
cut out there's a huge amount of people
and audience that are in this margin and
everyone below and this is important
because advertisers rely on returning
viewers to maximize the value of the ads
that they put on the site the creator's
who are in that margin now make less
videos because they're being forced off
the site this huge number of a returning
audience is now returning to the site
less and less and less and less and
advertisers want to spend less and less
money on the site because the value that
they get out of that returning audience
is lowered you've got a compounding
problem that's driving away returning
viewers and making advertising dollars
less and less valuable but it gets even
worse when a few additional factors are
considered first and foremost YouTube's
cultural impact in case you haven't
noticed more and more people return to
YouTube for daily entertainment than
ever before humanity watches 1 billion
hours of YouTube every single day with
average session times of 40 minutes or
more so like it or not YouTube is now
part of the public conscious
and with that comes the expectation and
the demand that the videos on the site
are safe to watch advertisement on the
site is now more carefully scrutinized
than it ever has been before so
advertisers have to be more and more
careful about what kind of content their
ads are associated with so if YouTube is
unable to create what I'll call correct
ad Association on the site which is in
line with like society's expectation
they put both themselves and advertisers
at risk as we saw with the apocalypse it
was in part spurred on by advertisements
from large corporations being associated
with highly inflammatory content on the
site this in turn sparked a wildfire of
advertisers pulling out of the site and
tell things cooled down enough for them
to jump back into it
because in general large corporations
avoid at all costs hot-button issues and
negative association so we've got
YouTube's unprecedented cultural impact
in addition to a disruption in the
underlying economic model well there's
one more factor that plays a part here
and most people don't know this YouTube
has never made a profit while Google
doesn't release official documents on
exactly what it costs to run YouTube
they've never reported profit they've
only reported loss since they bought the
site in late 2006 now go back and pair
this with the other two issues that we
were just talking about the underlying
economic model and the cultural impact
you introduce the problem of excess
supply and the YouTube Partnership
Program and the resulting loss and
important returning audiences across the
site and the downward spiral that that
creates at a certain point Google must
be putting pressure on them to come up
with a strategy that returns their
investment and makes a sustainable
future after all it is a business so
what steps would YouTube likely be
taking to fix these mounting issues that
could potentially threaten their entire
site well they're cutting the number of
partners in the YouTube Partnership
Program that's what they're doing if
this new current round of monetization
rules which now take away the ability of
millions of channels to monetize don't
work they'll just keep cutting channels
Intel there's a small enough body that
makes the finance
work even if they cut this down to just
10% there'd still be 1.3 million
channels in the YouTube Partnership
Program if you to cut this number of 13
million partners down to 1.3 million
average per capita revenue would go from
769 dollars to seven thousand six
hundred and sixty-nine dollars that
would clearly be a positive for the
channels left in the partnership program
and it would thereby further expand
their reach and revenue obviously this
would be completely disastrous for
anyone caught in the middle years of
hard work millions of viewers and the
creators who have risked everything to
make it on the site they would just be
abandoned and you undermine the
philosophy that had made the site
culturally significant in the first
place that hurts pretty bad but would
not doing so mean that YouTube couldn't
exist well I don't know if I would go
that far but I wouldn't say that it
would be improbable if YouTube again
raises minimum monetization requirements
just something like say now a minimum of
10 K subs and 40 K hours of watch time
in the previous year then we will know
that they haven't quite found the
balance that they're looking for and
they're gonna continue to do this and
tell the numbers work I have no idea how
this is gonna affect Sam and Nico or
corridor digital if we're gonna get
caught in the middle I know that there
will be thousands of people that will be
caught in the middle here and it's a
really really important issue it's gonna
affect a lot of viewers it's gonna
affect a lot of creators it's gonna
affect the whole site well that's all I
really have to say about this right now
if you have thoughts on it please put
them in the comments I'll be going
through I'll be responding if you'd like
to see more videos like this where we
dive into some of these deeper questions
in social media generally I really want
to do one about how algorithms are
having really really insane unintended
consequences on the way that we think on
opinions and ideas sometimes even
affecting extremist opinions and
ideologies so if you'd like to see
something like that consider subscribing
let us know and we will see you in the
future